another day another existential threat
to our democracy
i heard about this new threat yesterday
and when i checked to see where the
threat was coming from i learned that
just like in every great horror movie
this time
the threat was coming from inside the
house
if you go to facebook on a daily basis
the most the post with the most
engagement are from dan shapiro or ben
shapiro dan bongino candice owens it is
right-wing content it dwarfs progressive
content it dwarfs mainstream media
accounting which is actually should be
the part that scares us the most that
ben shapiro's daily wire has more
followers and engagement many times more
than the new york times or cnn that is a
problem for democracy
it's a problem that daily wire that was
dan pfeiffer dan pfeiffer is a former
obama staffer who now co-hosts his own
podcast and at first
i couldn't quite understand what mr
pfeiffer was saying
so i had a translator friend of mine who
is fluent in both english and lib
translate that for me and apparently
what pfeiffer was trying to communicate
is
wow
the daily wire is popular and more
popular than me and all my lib friends
and i don't like that wow
now the hardest word to make sense of in
pfeiffer's remarks is the word democracy
because democracy as you know is popular
government
and the only thing pfeiffer is accusing
us of is being popular
he's complaining because we are popular
and he and the rest of the libs despite
controlling
every major institution in the country
are not popular
and he's insinuating that to preserve
our democracy
our popular platform needs to be
suppressed and the lib's unpopular
platform needs to be amplified which is
about as anti-democratic as it gets
but when the libs use the word democracy
when they talk about our sacred
democracy the temple of our democracy
they don't really mean democracy they
just mean liberalism leftism
progressivism
that's what they fear is under threat
and they're absolutely right i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from horsehead who
says as creepy as the drag show was it's
worse still that there were parents who
were happy and willing to take their
kids to it doesn't say much for the
modern parent i think that's totally
true sort of how i feel about
transgenderism broadly or really any
other cultural pathology that's
spreading around like an epidemic
i don't
really blame the people who are in the
thrall of these
of these illnesses these sort of social
illnesses i don't blame the people who
are under the sway of these terrible
ideologies and
disorder desires and bizarre
identities that are that are harming
individuals and harming society
i i place much more blame at the foot of
the people who are promoting them at the
of the people who are enabling them you
don't you don't get angry at the
lunatic because he says he hears voices
in his head you get angry at the people
who are encouraging him and saying do
whatever those voices say oh absolutely
you've got 10 people living in your head
johnny that's right go right around
doing that those are the people who are
much more morally culpable because
they're the ones who are supposed to
know better they're supposed to be in
their right minds you know you certainly
don't blame a little kid for going to a
drag show but you sure as hell blame the
parents horrible horrible
parenting going on maybe the parents are
a little bit confused too when you want
to protect your family when you want to
protect your home you got to check out
ring right now go to ring.com
knowles it's the summer summer is busy
everyone's away from home for quite a
bit i just got back home last night or i
got back home two nights ago sweet
little elisa got back home last night
people are coming and going you want to
protect your home
you know about rings video doorbell you
can see and speak to whoever's on your
doorstep wherever you are in the world
whether you're in the house or on the
other side of the globe you know about
ring alarm that allows you to protect
your home your doors your windows from
freeze fire flood the bad guys too
but have you gone pro have you gotten
the ring alarm pro you got to be a pro
be like me go be a pro cnet calls ring
alarm pro a giant leap for home security
because it protects not just your
physical home but your digital home too
we live so much of our lives online now
we've got to protect those data we've
got to protect that digital life protect
your wifi router protect your physical
home too go to ring.com
knowles this is where you go to learn
more to protect your home your physical
life your digital life and everything in
between ring.com
knowles
big threats to democracy
coming from
the daily wire really i guess coming
from you because you're the people who
listen to this stuff you're the people
who tune in and give us
way better ratings than
the all of the lib outlets even though
we're a really small outfit that was
just born out of a pool house on ventura
boulevard now all of a sudden we're
we're much more popular
on social media than than the libs are
and it's your fault because you're the
ones doing that and that's a big threat
to democracy when the people want
something the libs don't like
you see the same kind of argument
when it comes to abortion right now
the louisiana legislature the
representatives of the people of
louisiana just passed a really great
bill it's a bill that makes it illegal
to ship abortion drugs so the the bill
passed the legislature on friday it's uh
you know headed to the desk of the
governor john bel edwards who's a
democrat
senate bill 388 would make it illegal
for any company to provide abortion
inducing drugs myth mifa pristone and
misoprostol by the mail it passed by a
lot it was a 31-1 victory in the state
senate
this this would be considered a victory
for democracy right because the people
want it the people overwhelmingly want
this bill to be passed and yet the way
that the libs will talk about this is as
a grave threat to democracy they did it
when when donald trump got elected
president in 2016. they said oh no more
people voted for trump than voted for
our person this is a threat to democracy
they do it in europe when victor orban
the conservative leader of hungary when
he won when he when he keeps winning
when he keeps remaining so popular they
say gosh his popularity the fact that
people keep voting for him that's a
grave threat to democracy this of course
is a nonsensical statement it doesn't
mean anything
it's it's
in intrinsically incoherent right to say
that more
the greatest number of people voting for
something is anti-democratic except you
realize that they could just conflate
their own ideology liberalism leftism
progressivism with
democracy and this is why they can never
lose
in their own minds this is why they
never
they never concede at least in their
hearts the elections that they lose this
is why hillary clinton still hasn't
conceded 2016. this is why democrats
still haven't conceded the bush v gore
election of 2000. this is why stacey
abrams hasn't conceded in georgia
those are elections that had nowhere
near the kind of shenanigans that we saw
in the 2020 presidential election
nowhere near the kind of upending of the
election rules that we saw in the last
presidential and yet they won't concede
it because it just doesn't make sense
the people are supposed to vote for us
if they knew their true interests if
they really knew if they weren't being
lied to with misinformation and and if
they weren't being enchanted by the
sorcerers on the republican side they
would vote for us and so there must be
something that's gone wrong it must be
illegitimate this is a an old marxist
idea the idea that they're the when they
lose when the libs lose when the
radicals lose it's because the people
have been thrown under the sway of a
false consciousness
they're voting against their own
interests this is why the libs are so
mean to black conservatives and women
conservatives and gay conservatives and
the reason they're so mean to them is
they say you belong to us if you knew
your best interest you you would be
voting for us and so it's not your fault
but it's those evil republicans who have
enchanted you with their sorcery and
you're just too big of an idiot to
realize it so we've gotta we've gotta
upend this entire system because the way
it's operating right now is is certainly
unfair it's not a true democracy because
in true democracy only we ever win that
that's that is the logic behind all of
these sorts of claims
that's what they're that's what they're
talking about with abortion you look at
abortion majority of pro-lifers are
women they say no they're all just
they're just under a false consciousness
no it's a threat to democracy speaking
of women's issues
the carolina panthers this is an nfl
team that i don't follow and i certainly
don't intend to follow now
they've got a cheerleading squad just
like all football teams do so they got
this cheerleading squad frankly it's my
favorite part of football games
not anymore
because the carolina panthers
cheerleading squad
will now feature a man
dressed as a woman
doing all the cheers
the man goes by justine simone lindsey
something tells me that's not his real
name but that's what he goes by now and
uh he announced on instagram that he is
now
uh going to join the panthers top cats
and this was confirmed by the
cheerleading director sean delay lanuet
to buzzfeed
obviously wrong obviously gross
obviously
no normal person wants to see this
so why is it happening
the reason it's happening is not just
because this guy has some sexual
disorders
the reason it's happening is not just
because our society has lost its mind on
this fad right now this this fashionable
ideology that says that men can secretly
be women which is going to fall out of
fashion at some point but right now it's
really really hot
there's a deeper reason that this is
happening
it's actually even beyond the weird
sexual
confusion and sexual ideologies the
deeper reason this is happening is
because of selfishness because
increasingly the only people that we
ever consider in our entire public life
is ourselves me me me me
the question you've got to ask yourself
when
in a sane society insane football team
in the same cheerleading squad
when someone applies to be a cheerleader
the first question you got to ask
yourself is how will this help
the cheerleading squad
not how will this help the individual
who's applying it's not about them it's
about the team
at first it's about the squad and then
when you're talking about cheerleading
it's not even just about the
cheerleading team it's about the
football team the question you got to
ask yourself is what is cheerleading for
what's it for is cheerleading for
making sexually confused men feel
temporarily better about themselves
maybe if it even does that or is
cheerleading for
cheering on the team
cheering on the football team in this
case
what is it for this actually really
began even before the gender ideology
took off
because
in the way olden days you had
cheerleaders and the cheerleaders would
show up to the football games and throw
the pom-poms in the air and say wow go
team
then
sometime within the last few decades
cheerleading became its own sport so you
would have a friend of mine would do
this cheerleader friends of mine would
do this they'd go to cheerleading
competitions
but but a cheerleading competition
doesn't make any sense
because the purpose of cheerleading is
to cheer on the team if you take the
team out of it and you've just got the
cheerleaders cheerleading becomes
something entirely different now some
people say well cheerleading is very
difficult yeah it can certainly can be
cheerleading is kind of like gymnastics
yeah it is if you want to do that join
the gymnastics team but it doesn't it
doesn't make any sense to make
cheerleading just about itself
cheerleading is intrinsically something
about other people we don't make sense
of that anymore we don't understand
anymore that something can be beyond
ourselves that the point of something
can be beyond our own desires and and
pleasure that actually there we have to
think of other people
and other people's views and society and
the objective reality and all it goes it
goes
all the way from the craziest example
which is these dudes who are pretending
to be chicks all the way down to the
totally ordinary facets of life which
used to be about the common good which
used to be about serving your family and
your community and your god and now in
virtually every aspect of life have been
turned on ourselves and a man
wrapped up in himself makes a very small
package indeed especially when he's
wearing a cheerleading uniform when you
want to protect
your home you got to check out american
home shield right now go to ahs.com
knowles it has never been more important
than right now to stay on a budget the
thing the economy is going all over the
place things are getting much more
expensive and you know the one thing you
can expect is the unexpected that is why
american home shield exists as a member
you know that your budget time and your
sanity are covered choose a plan from
american home shield and keep your
budget goals in check for 2022. they
offer a choice of three great plans to
help cover the cost to repair or replace
parts of major home systems and
appliances no matter their age if
american home shield can't repair a
covered item they will replace it
american home shield members get more
more coverage options fewer exclusions
from hvac systems and plumbing to
kitchen appliances their plans help
protect parts of up to 23 essential home
systems and appliances electronics
coverage is available for an unlimited
number of eligible items smart watches
flat screen tvs pool coverage spa
coverage you you can get so much covered
with ahs so keep your home up and
running budget back on track with
american home shield our listeners can
take 50 off their most comprehensive
plans ever right now ahs.com
knowles save 50 bucks that's ahs.com
slash knowles for 50 off any american
home shield plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply see plan for details
speaking of misidentifying things we're
we're really bad at identifying things
these days you know we identify
men as women we identify babies as
meaningless clumps of cells we don't
seem to be able to recognize anything
anymore and now in california
we are identifying bees
like bumble bees
as fish
the tell me this story doesn't tell you
everything you need to know about
california and the present state of our
culture bees are now legally fish
in california
what is it b that's going to be my next
movie what is a fish that's going to be
a feature-length film from the daily
wire very very controversial what is a
fish
this according to the sacramento bee
actually bees are legally fish in
california court rules here's why and
what led to it
here's what led to it
there was an act in 1970
designed to protect endangered species
and the act explicitly protected fish
and then the fish they defined as
invertebrates
now the act since 1970 has been applied
to protect
land dwelling in vertebrates such as
snails
therefore
the california court of appeals
has decided that a terrestrial
invertebrate like the bumblebee may be
listed as an endangered or threatened
species under the act which protects
fish
do you see the logic here
it's not logic it's illogic but but
it it
describes or it shows you
how the libs operate in politics
they passed this law in 1970 and it says
we're going to protect fish
and they do protect fish they spend a
lot of time they waste all of the
[Music]
limited water supply in california
protecting the little delta smelt so
they were very focused on protecting the
fish and then later on they said we want
to protect the snails too
but they didn't go back and pass a new
law i don't know exactly why they didn't
go past a new law one of the reasons
might be that californians are generally
sick of these laws protecting these tiny
little species at the at the cost of
humans living a flourishing life so you
divert the fresh water from human beings
to the delta smelt in the snail so maybe
that's why i don't know i'm not sure why
they couldn't pass a law between 1970
and today to say okay we're also going
to protect the snails
but they didn't they just had a court
rule and said actually snails are fish
and now you get up all the way to the
year of our lord 2022 52 years later and
they say yeah and if it's okay if snails
are fish then also bumblebees are fish
too instead of just going and passing
along saying we're going to protect the
bumblebee down
you probably can't get through that that
through the political process and so
they say okay we're just going to
manipulate language
to
meanings that have absolutely nothing to
do with with
what the word originally meant
and we're going to do that to ram
through our political agenda
coincidentally or providentially my book
on this very topic
just came out today
in paperback
this would be speechless controlling
words controlling minds the number one
national bestseller thanks to you you
are the reason that that book became a
number one national bestseller around
the country snubbed by the new york
times i couldn't be more honored because
listen our platform dwarfs the new york
times so who needs them
we don't need those guys to put us on
their editorial list uh that the book is
now out in paperback because it's sold
very well in hardcover so you can go
pick up a copy today at amazon barnes
and noble indie books wherever wherever
fine books are sold i think we're
selling it in the daily wire store
actually so that's probably the best
place to go buy it
if bees can be fish
then anything can be anything else a
real sign of the times i have nothing
against the bees but bees are not fish
men are not women babies are not
meaningless clumps of cells bees are not
fish do you notice too with the these
environmental laws from the libs
they always seem to exempt themselves
they always seem to push the burden of
their pie in the sky schemes
unto everyone else
but not unto themselves and they say
we're the humanitarians the reason we're
passing this sort of protection the
reason we're passing this punitive
measure against a certain industry is
not to enrich ourselves or protect
ourselves no no it's to protect mother
earth it's to protect humanity and
that's why all you peasants you have to
bear the costs of this and we ourselves
will not that's what you're seeing right
now in the european union
the eu
is
uh
instituting a pollut an aviation fuel
pollution
tax
corporate jets will be exempted
so
so commercial jets well
the jets that all of us fly around on
when we need to go visit grandma for
christmas or when we want to go on
vacation maybe or whenever we want to
get anywhere we're going to have to pay
that tax
but
the wealthy corporate executives who
have their own private jets they don't
need to pay that tax can there be any
explanation for this
other than
preferential treatment for themselves
can there be any
explanation for this other than
forcing you and i and really really the
people in europe to pay for their
privileges i can't think of one
and furthermore it shows that they're
probably not all that serious about
climate change global warming global
cooling the sun monster they're probably
not all that worried about that you know
they're not all that worried about that
because they're not selling their
beachfront property you know they're not
all worried about that because they fly
around on their private jets already to
go to their climate change conferences
and pontificate about how you and i need
to eat bugs and never leave our homes
and go buy a tesla
although they probably don't want us to
buy a tesla anymore because elon musk
turned on them
they already do that now they don't even
want to pay the extra fuel tax on their
private jets that they're making all the
rest of us pay on commercial flights
do we really believe they think the
world is going to end in 10 years or
actually some people predicted the world
would already end
i believe
prince charles in the uk predicted the
world would already end
though he's not really the object of my
ire it's not it's not even really him
it's these
liberal technocratic corporate
people who i think someone like a prince
charles
i think he actually likes the
environment and i think he likes it
because he walks around in his
three-piece suits and he's walking
around his beautiful gardens we need to
protect the environment so that they
have somewhere to stroll in the
afternoon so that they can go shoot
animals and the weekends and look at my
beautiful estates
and i really respect that actually i'm
all for protecting the environment in
order to give us beautiful places to
live in
my problem is one the crazy radicals the
ideologues who want to protect the
environment from human beings who say
that basically humans are a plague on
the planet and we need to get rid of the
human beings so that the delta smelt can
live freely again those guys and then
the cynical people who don't really
believe any of this crap and who who
realize that it can just give them a leg
up politically
which i think makes up a much larger
portion of the environmental liberal
establishment these guys who say we're
so we're so worried about protecting the
climate that we're not going to pay any
of the taxes that we're going to force
you people to pay
but they use it to take power you're
seeing this right now in the white house
joe biden is it is
invoking the defense production act to
produce green energy and solar panels
now the defense production act
requires an emergency the point of the
defense production act is in the face of
an emergency the president can move very
very quickly to produce certain goods
well
what is the emergency causing us to
produce these extremely inefficient
kinds of technologies that usually just
line the pockets of democrat donors the
white house can't quite say
what emergency is the president using to
invoke the defense production act
because historically it's been in the
1950s uh for the the korean war during
covet it was enacted what emergency is
it or what's the real emergency in the
solar industry for the defense
production act um so
let me uh i was going to say first the
president you know when he takes the
defense protection act is to make sure
that he's delivering for the american
people uh it is an important tool that
he has used a couple of times and it has
been incredibly
effective uh so uh for this particular
clean energy defense production act he
is invoking the defense production act
to rapidly expand domestic production
of solar panel parts building insulation
heat pumps and more he is putting the
full force
of the federal government's purchasing
power behind supporting american clean
energy manufacturers and he is providing
u.s solar deployers the short-term
stability they need to build clean
energy projects and deliver more
affordability energy to american
families and business
cool so karine can you answer the
question at all she's pretty weak at at
least gensake could usually give a glib
kind of answer to whatever the question
is or get in a little zinger even if it
wasn't all that effective but karine
jean-pierre she goes uh uh i don't i
didn't even think about i don't remember
uh kaylee mcinerney used to have binders
with answers pre-written to all of the
questions she could possibly be asked
karine has no idea how to answer even
very basic questions they say hey
and this is probably a liberal
journalist i'm not sure exactly who that
reporter is but statistically he's
probably a liberal
he's there and he says
why is the president invoking the
defense production what's the emergency
what what is he she goes uh uh
the defense production act is to deliver
for the american people she just says i
don't need to give you an answer i don't
need we're just going to do whatever we
want through sheer force of will
speaking of wills you should finish up
your will and protect your family that's
why you need to check out epic will
right now go to epicwill.com enter promo
code knowles life happens fast and it
can end even faster don't want to be a
debbie downer but this is important to
plan for this stuff okay you picture
yourself living to a ripe old age
doesn't always work out that way if it
doesn't you're going to want to have a
plan in place otherwise the state people
that you probably don't really trust
people who are trying to indoctrinate
your kids take away your guns steal all
your rights and traditions they're going
to step in and take control of your
assets when you're gone they're going to
determine what legacy you leave behind
don't do that
don't let our corrupt ruling class step
in and decide what happens to your kids
should god forbid something happen to
you don't let those people decide who
gets your gold or your crypto or your
comic book collection okay instead take
five minutes get a will set up through
epic will it starts at just 119 dollars
we love these guys we trust them to
protect the daily wire i just finished
up my will a couple of weeks ago
go to epicwill.com use promo code
knowles you'll get a 10 discount on epic
will's complete will package takes only
five minutes to set up many many of our
families at the daily wire are now
protected thanks to epic will why don't
you do the same go to epicwheel.com
enter promo code knowles and do
something for you and your family today
the daily wire
is churning content so quickly we are
just like a fire hose of content and you
can't keep a lid on it you know we had
what is a woman just come out you know
we've got terror on the prairie
premiering june 14th we had fauci
unmasked my docuseries we had the
abortion movie that came we just uh
which is the legacy of roe we we've got
all of this content coming out and
you've got to be a member
to see it go to dailywire.com subscribe
get access exclusive access to the
entire library of documentaries shows
and more of people have been writing in
especially since we released matt's
movie what is a woman and they say look
if this content's so good you should
just release it for free why won't you
you clearly you just want to make money
or something
i
i'm all for spreading the message as you
know the message costs money this kind
of content is so
incredibly expensive to make this is not
just some little mom and pop
coming out of jeremy's pool house
anymore we are taking on hollywood real
hollywood not with a little two-bit
operation but with a big massive
operation we're taking on the news media
we've got msnbc and the obama bros
quaking in their freaking boots because
of the kind of influence that
conservatives are finally beginning to
have and the only way we can do it is
with your support that's why we're so
grateful to all of the daily wire
members who have joined who have
supported us who are part of the team
and if you wanna if you wanna watch this
content really if you just wanna stick
it to the libs who have been trying to
keep us out for a long time uh please go
over and join we'll be right back with a
lot more
last year a group of washington state
gender identity lgbt sexual
revolutionary non-profit organizations
all of which work with children and
receive tax payer money hosted a
presentation series called
decolonizing gender we have these clips
thanks to chris ruffo he has been
absolutely incredible exposing what this
kind of ideology means for people
critical race theory
a little bit on the on the gender front
all this radicalism that we're seeing
in schools
and in extracurricular
activities
aimed at students
in many cases with your taxpayer money
one you've got to first recognize the
fact that these kinds of organizations
are receiving taxpayer money
means that they are
an enforcement arm of the political left
they're not as accountable as the
government would be because they're not
technically part of the government
they're just outside the government but
they receive that government money so
they get to they have a lot more freedom
in brainwashing your kids they do it's
in a way it's sort of like blm blm goes
around and torches the country for eight
months and they're not really held
accountable
and they're they're certainly not held
accountable in the way that a public
official would because they're not
public officials they're the enforcement
arm of the democrat party
more broadly of the liberal
establishment so
at a really basic level
a lot of this ideology comes down to
money because money
is power
so folks watching um i think another way
that you can support people who are
doing community work if you have like
access to generational wealth if you're
white
and your parents you know like have like
a savings account that is you know very
much so connected to slavery and land
theft you know pay people pay people
directly give them the money so they can
have the financial security in order to
rest and to heal and to connect um with
their communities in a way that they
wouldn't have to because they've been
working because they've been doing this
work we've always been doing this work
um so yeah i think randy brought this up
before but like pay that money you know
reparations like pay that money to us
now because we need that we don't have
especially for black indigenous folks we
don't have like um
you know a safety net in order to take
that time to heal um and it can be a
privilege for some so um if you have
those resources share them um and you
know let's all just it's healing can
also be like a collective thing too it
takes like a it takes a village you know
as an african proverb would say it takes
a village so um we all have to do this
together and support one another
what a hustle
you know when daley wire says hey please
join daily wire we're giving you this
movie this movie this show this content
this thing we're really trying to say
look you're getting way more value for
your money than every dollar you're
putting in these guys they say hey give
me money what are you going to get you
get i won't be as angry with you
maybe i won't burn the country down this
year
hey it's a nice country you got here
sure would be a shame if i burned it
down again
give me that money hey you spare a
little change it's like a a derelict who
comes up to you in a dark alley at night
hey man could you spare a little change
well we're in this dark alley and you're
standing there in a fairly threatening
posture i guess i have to give you some
money yeah give that to us because of
all the oppression or whatever you know
man institutional generational whatever
write a check give me that money give me
that money so that's what a lot of it
comes down to and in this woman's i
don't know is it a woman
the the person who was speaking hat
seemed to have a lot of chest hair
i don't i think that's chest hair but
kind of anyway i don't know it's very
confusing we're living in a very
confusing time but this person
actually has a point which is that
money is
power big politics attracts big money
and big money attracts big political
power and so what this person is saying
is we need this money
uh right now because that's the way that
we're really going to affect change and
to some degree there's a point to that
we don't want the change that that they
are going to
affect so
at the basic level yeah this is a
regular old political operation in many
ways it's no different than the mob the
second thing that this conference
exposed though is just it's a point we
were talking about earlier the sheer
selfishness the sheer self-obsession of
this entire ideology
you know i don't see myself as 100 women
even though i use transfem trans women
interchangeably all the time you know um
i take hormones so that i have breasts
you know so i can appear whatever a way
so you can again interpret
what my soul is but if i were to tell
you like oh yeah i want to be called
non-binary transform my whole life no i
don't i just want to be called randy
aisha you know those you know whatever i
want you to call me you know mommy queen
daddy if i want you to
i want to see people you know my young
people they when i would bring up
pronouns they would come up with wakanda
they would come up with pokemon trainer
they would come up with whatever was on
their heart and i was like that is the
world i want to see we're calling
ourselves cyborgs we're calling ourself
whatever we need in order to feel good
about ourselves like why can't we just
feel good about ourselves and affirm
ourselves and people respect that so
yeah i definitely think gender needs to
go
does this guy sound like he feels good
about himself
he doesn't sound to me like someone who
feels good about himself people who feel
good about themselves
don't constantly need the affirmation of
others
he sounds to me like the opposite of
someone who feels good about himself
when you really feel
comfortable confident
good right about what you're doing
not only do you not need the affirmation
of others but you can stand tall even as
everyone else is attacking you
some people know this when you're
standing up for something that's right
very often people attack you look what
look what they did to jesus look what
they did to socrates look what they did
to people who have spoken the truth
certainly to the man who is the truth
but even to other people throughout
history who have had the gall to speak
the truth what happens to them they get
attacked
that's the way it goes this is a fallen
world
and the people who feel good about
themselves
stand stand tall i was just reading the
apology of of socrates by plato i was
just going through my western
civilization series happened a few
nights ago to be reading the apology of
socrates and
socrates is there he's standing before
the athenians he knows that they're
going to kill him
and he says look don't listen
i don't really care if you kill me or
not because i'm just going to do the
right thing and but it's going to be
really bad for you if you kill me
because you will be doing the wrong
thing and if you're doing the wrong
thing that's that's really bad because
it's much better to be just than to be
unjust
and it's much worse to harm someone else
than to be harmed yourself totally
rational
argument and you see it throughout the
speeches of plato's socrates
you see this in the credo you see that
you
this guy does not feel good about
himself and he says the world that i
want to see is a world where i can be
whatever i forget about he or she forget
about male or female i want to be randy
or aisha wait hold on i thought you just
said you told me what to call you you
said call me randy no until i want to be
aisha until i want to be a pokemon until
i want to be this the world i want to
live in what what he is saying and what
the gender movement broadly is saying is
i want to live in a world
without logic without reason without
intellect
without any objective standard by which
anyone can tell if anything is true or
false
what what they are saying is i want to
live in a world of pure will
of pure
tyranny of will where the words that we
say don't make any sense pokemon jiggly
bear up and down
chocolate vanilla hot dog
that's that's the world they want to
live in a world where we're just making
sounds like grunting animals and all we
are doing is feeding our own appetites
our own
lower will he's in many ways that guy
randy slash aisha slash the pokemon
is acknowledging what the conservatives
have been saying about transgenderism
there was another guy this last guy i
thought was the most important part of
this conference it's really important to
watch these clips when conservatives
like chris ruffo are able to to bring
them to us they they get a scoop they
get a leak and they bring them to us
it's important it's important to watch
lives of tic-toc because
one it tells you what what really lies
at the heart of these bizarre social
movements that often leave people
scratching their heads what do you mean
a man as a woman it tells you what they
really believe about it and very often
the way that the radicals view these
things
are not all that different from the way
that conservatives do there was a guy
who spoke at at the end of this
conference thread
and and he said that he knew that he was
transgender pan gender gender whatever
when he was a little kid being called
into the woods by spirits
for me when i was growing up colonialism
looked a lot like my first introduction
to quantism looked a lot like
me waking up
at you know four in the morning five in
the morning
every morning to you know
sounds of you know my ancestors
screaming from outside my window
um coming from the the ground coming
from the earth
um and nature outside you know like
waking me up to tell me that like hey
there is work to be done but that's what
really radicalized me at a very young
age amongst many other things
you know
hearing those screams every morning is
what really radicalized me because there
are things that most other folks around
me including my my mother could not hear
um and they are things that they that
you know that did not affect those
individuals in the same way
um
and i carried that i followed those
screams you know into the woods as a
child
my parents you know didn't really like
watch me very more parents sorry should
i say didn't really watch me very much
uh growing up so i often wandered into
the woods and was taught
um by my ancestors in those woods you
know in the forms of nature spirits um
in the forms of elementals and the forms
of you know natural deities and old gods
you know while i was out there you know
i was taught many things and
you know my mind was decolonized in that
way
so what this guy is saying is that
the way he became
radical
transgender extreme far left what the
way he
got to where he is today
is that he came from a broken home
right he says my my parents oh sorry i
mean my parent
a broken home where he was neglected
i wasn't watched very much by my parent
as a kid a broken home where he was
neglected and then spent a long time in
isolation
and then he got screwed up by demons
that's what he's saying
that's his description of what happened
oh yeah why am i all messed up and
his name is or he goes by ganesha gold
buffalo he's a male prostitute who says
that he's a woman and identifies as
transgender he says how did i get to
where i am how did i become the man
or not man that i am today
why i came from a broken home
and spent a ton of time in isolation
alone being neglected
and then demons convinced me
to that the world is different than it
actually is
the way that this radical transgender
guy is describing
transgenderism and
his radical views more broadly
is virtually indistinguishable from the
way that a conservative christian would
describe it
we're both yes i think that in the case
of
transgenderism there's
definitely the question of mental
illness i mean it's just by definition
one would have to be mentally ill to be
a man to believe that he's a woman
but there are a lot of social conditions
and it seems to come from some broken
homes and it seems to come from some
child abuse
it seems to come from long periods of
time in isolation and it seems to come
from demonic influence let's just call a
spade a spade he says it the transgender
guy says it i say it a christian guy
says it the only people who don't say it
are the liberals in the middle
the materialist liberals who say oh no
it's not no it's not a big none of
that's true listen to the radicals
listen to the radicals themselves the
radicals themselves seem to agree with
the conservative christians
and those are all bad things
all of the influences that led this guy
to become a
male prostitute calling himself a woman
a decolonizer or whatever
are all bad things broken homes neglect
child abuse and especially demons
they're bad they're bad they're real and
they're bad
speaking of libs missing really really
basic things
everyone is turning on joe biden except
for the establishment liberals
but everyone else's not just the
conservatives
not just the the people who have been
radicalized to the even
cardi b
the well-known economist
sterling professor of economics dr cardi
b professor b said
quote
when y'all think they're going to
announce that we going into a recession
when you all think they're going to do
that
cardi b knows that the economy is in bad
shape have you bought food recently
i bought food last night and i was
shocked at how expensive it is
the only reason i wasn't more shocked is
because i bought food somewhat recently
bought food last week too and i was
shocked then and how expensive it is you
buy gas recently you pay for anything
recently
you look at the fundamentals of our
economy recently
you look at your stock portfolio your
retirement account recently
things are not looking good in the
economy
cardi b knows it
the conservatives know it
the only people who don't seem to know
it
or don't want to admit it or don't even
care
or the establishment liberals who still
insist to us this is the greatest
economic recovery ever in our
imaginations in the same place where men
are women and babies aren't really
babies that's where the economy is
flourishing
speaking of our economy
there was a video that went viral
yesterday on the internet
people talking about what what terrible
things this means for the american
economy and it was this i thought
generally charming video of two young
women sitting in a pool with their
laptops describing how they're doing
their job from
from the pool deck because they don't
need to go into an office right now
my co-workers keep saying i need to make
like a tech
tick tock because if you look at my tick
tock you'd never guess i have a job
so um
anyways this is our current workstation
cali and i are what you call product
managers
cali what is your team over
my team is over recording and internal
tools
and i am over what we call card
experience
so we work on like anything from
activating your credit card to freezing
reissue
shipping all the good stuff
um what's a pm
we help prioritize and help the
engineers stay on track and help them
know what to build
so that you have a product to use yeah
exactly so you might have a team like
the engineers actually do the developing
the coding which is the impressive part
designers also do the impressive part
which is everything you see when you're
in a software product managers
essentially decide what the team's going
to work on do competitive research
prioritize bugs keep everyone focused
motivated and driving towards business
outcomes so
that's what we do
i found this video very charming i'd
everyone was dunking on these girls why
are they dunking on these girls
so these girls have an easy job
okay that's fine people have had easy
jobs before
the girls are saying yeah in our job we
it doesn't even look like we have a job
because we're just on tick tock all day
and we sit out here by the pool all day
and yeah we don't and we can we're
making a tick tock about sitting out at
the pool about how our job is really
easy
okay i don't begrudge them that
they're also young girls they look like
they're in their 20s they're probably
if i'm just taking out my nostradamus
out here in my crystal ball they're
probably
just going to like meet a guy in their
20s and get married and they're not pro
what i'm saying is they're probably not
100 totally driven by their career nor
should they be that's fine i don't think
we all need to be automatons slaving
away in some box all day long doing
spreadsheets for mr jenkins to to get
some more dollars to go consume more
stuff in the economy that's not good for
them they get to sit out by the pool
the the legitimate
fear i think the legitimate criticism
that comes from this video is
it look it's fine if some people have
those jobs especially if they have other
interests in their life and they don't
want to do this forever and they want to
move on and have a family and do other
things the fear is when everyone's doing
that
we can't have a country where everyone
is sitting out by the pool
making tick tocks about how they're not
doing their actual job
or how they are but their actual job
doesn't require them to do very much
when the entire economy is doing that
then we're really in trouble
and that's the place we are right now
after two years from the very beginning
of the lockdowns
i thought this is a bad thing
because what i know is you don't get
something for nothing
you you can't you can't just sit around
all day and not do it everything and
still have a flourishing country that's
growing and vibrant it doesn't work
when people point out that communist
societies
have terrible stagnant economies
very often we don't explain why that is
or we don't think about why that is
the reason communist economies are so
terrible
is because people don't work there it's
because the incentives don't exist for
people to go out and do work
so that the people in communist
countries
often are pretty lazy
they often are not very driven they're
disincentivized from going out and doing
work there is a structural problem there
but that that's why and if we're living
in a country where we're all just doing
that now we're all just sitting by the
pool taking tick tocks sipping our pina
coladas
occasionally
typing some buttons on our laptop we're
not going to have a flourishing
country
we need to go out and do things we need
to do things that are bigger than
ourselves
unfortunately we we've gotten into this
mindset of well listen if i if there's
even a slight chance that i could get a
slight cough
from a virus that doesn't really pose a
particularly great threat to me
then i'm just gonna sit home for two
years
well if i'm if i have to go out there
and do anything extra
that's going to detract from my going to
brunch and sitting at home
and
buying on lots of nice fun cool gizmos
and gadgets then i just don't want to do
that that mindset is is death
for a country
we have to think beyond ourselves beyond
our own pleasure beyond how we want to
be called beyond what we think usually
mistakenly will make us feel really good
i mean you think what's this about
what's this for
what is my role here you know in in
matt's documentary
my favorite scene
actually didn't have very much to do
with the question of western
transgenderism
my favorite scene was when that
professor got really angry with matt for
questioning his entire uh
science you know the gender studies that
was my favorite scene my second favorite
scene and i felt the most meaningful one
is when matt flies to africa and he's
talking to the tribals in kenya and he
said he says what is a woman
and they have a good answer but it's a
different answer than the westerners
would have westerners will often say a
woman is an adult
female human being what's a female well
female is distinguished by
by female reproductive
organs and capacity by the production of
eggs by the right you know you go down
this and when when matt asks the tribals
in kenya they said a woman is someone
who does the duties of the woman a woman
is someone who bears children who's
distinguished by that biological feature
but then by a social role as well
and he interviews the women too and
they're laughing at this idea of
transgender they're like no we do we do
the the things that women do and we
behave in the way that women behave and
we are women
and the men do the things that men do
and and some of the things that men do
seem pretty unpleasant i don't want to
do that and some of the things that we
do are kind of unpleasant the men don't
want to do that but we have a role
we have a place here
we've reversed that we we've convinced
ourselves mistakenly that having a role
and having a purpose and having natural
limits is going to make us all miserable
but there's really no escaping limits
and there's no escaping ultimately doing
stuff so you see it especially with the
way that feminism crack down the family
is in the 70s the feminist said a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
and women need to leave the home they
shouldn't even be allowed to stay home
and raise their families that's so
oppressive
instead of
helping their families and working for
their families
they need to go out and work for some
other guy who doesn't care about them at
the widget factory and go do
spreadsheets all the time until the guy
throws throws the woman out
there but there's no escaping does
anyone really believe that's more
liberating does anyone really believe
that's better for the woman or will lead
to a more flourishing life of course not
this is a key conservative insight and
edmund burke wrote about this at great
length
we want roles we want to feel like we're
doing good not just for ourselves but
for other people because a man or woman
or bumblebee or fish wrapped up in
himself makes a small package indeed i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the benton shapiro show new
polling data shows americans are in a
terrible mood and democrats are set to
pay the 2022 price msnbc plus a former
top obama official call for censoring
this show and the daily wire and
democrats planning january 6th hearing
extravaganza to try to stave off
electoral doom that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen